[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now it's
time anybody in the audience guess what
we were just talking about
i guarantee you can't uh welcome back to
the breakthrough new rockstars live show
coming at you direct from our actual
break room here at new rockstars
headquarters we're thrilled to have you
we hope you're thriving and alive and
out there uh and we've we've got a great
panel here to talk about the nerdy news
of the day
uh we're gonna get into like uh the
future of the dc eu uh some fantastic
four maybe news uh and and we're gonna
seek some snacks into the movie theater
but
to do that with me i'm jack cuddlestone
and i've got my esteemed panel here of
we got brandon barrack yeah if the
police are watching i've never snuck
anything into a movie okay i don't i
don't go to jail for experience if
you're a cop and you're watching you
have to play yeah you have to yeah i am
a child
yeah are there any cops you have to put
a cab in the chat no
the statue of limitations on raising
nets is like oh thank goodness 20 years
ago by the time they melt it's already
over
uh we got the wonderful jessica clements
here i have never snuck uh
any kind of snack into a movie theater
but i do torrent everything
you wouldn't download a bag of popcorn
would you
uh and then we're thrilled to go to
friend yes thank you phil sorry i'll
i'll take it because he's my friend
i see the
yeah yeah uh uh we can't call out the
chats excited for you oh no i meant that
we were all talking about stealing pogba
okay
about me
our good friend we i discovered him i
discovered him
apparently i was plucking 10 percent of
everything he does uh
uh i made this guy uh no i watched a lot
of real rejects content that he kept
appearing on and then i see this guy
everywhere yeah and here's my favorite
thing about him he knows this
s
yeah we'll talk about that in a second
thank you koi for joining us so excited
to be here um also we were we were
joking you know when tommy bechtel's not
here it takes an army to replace them
really you probably need four or five
more people to bring the amount of
energy but i have full faith that philip
and uh coy are
better than equipped uh to replace this
tommy and to be clear i am philip molina
oh yes
you did a good job
real quick i'll say for movie theater uh
crimes i absolutely dated someone for a
long time for only the free movies can i
say i've been on the other side of that
i worked in the theater for six years
and definitely was dated for a long time
for free movies i've experienced all of
this and someone could have just tore
into them
here we are all right stephanie amc your
first girlfriend
what would uh what would nicole kidman
feel about all this heartbreak feels a
little better to play yes
uh and uh whoppers just tastes better in
a place like this um let's get into oh
as philip mentioned
today we have a redemption for super
chats we appreciate everybody in the
chat right now everybody who's throwing
us a couple shekels couple doubloons um
including jeff burst i'm sorry i
mispronounced your name he got in there
early thank you jeff
but if we hit a multiple of a hundred
dollars that unlocks
our swear jar we are not allowed to
curse otherwise philip already edited
himself really well beautiful said he
said that coin knew his ass
but oh you guys thought i was going to
say a curse word yes
now i'll never tell you what else you
want to say cinema
yeah okay uh but if we hit that it
unlock it unlocks the square jar and
when that thing unlocks it's like
pandora's box the profanity that spews
fourth is pretty wild again i i a lot of
these things on the show get run by me
this is not what i approve that's right
but fine no no no this thing this thing
it was a seed planted and it grew out
funky no one approved it it just it
happened yeah it got wet and then this
happened yeah the show has become
sentient
we fed it after midnight and now we've
got a swear jar um but let's get into
our headlines
it doesn't show up unless you
some people are watching this show in 3d
yeah exactly two people still have three
big tv's
such a little weirdo you can't even see
it
we can't see it the cameraman our best
friend daschle is in front of it for us
thanks daschle best friend
uh so the headlines of the day it's it's
a little bit of a lighter news day but
we've got some interesting
conversation starters so there's been a
lot of speculation you know we're warner
media owner of warner brothers hbo among
other things and discovery owner of a
lot of other cable networks and whatever
there oh yeah uh they're merging
actually
so i'll weigh in as appropriate okay
yeah as an insider when we talk about
subway restaurants
once we get the jamba juice i can't wait
to tell everyone
they're merging and so you know one of
the kind of key properties of warner
brothers is the dc
eu dc
hbo max properties cw shows all that
kind of stuff falls under there there's
been a lot of speculation especially
about the dc eu we know we got a shazam
coming we know we got a flash coming we
know we got an aquaman 2 come in we
don't know much else we don't know about
the direction that that's going uh we
don't know about plans beyond these
three movies um and there's there was
kind of a rumor that sprung up in the
last 24 48 hours that joker director
todd phillips
might be
having a bigger influence on the future
of the dc eu than was previously
speculated his name has not been floated
around much in fact a lot of people
thought like he's just gonna do this
one-on-one joker movie it's not even
connected to the rest of the dcu but
supposedly he might be a part of this
like kind of long-term plan that's the
reason why i don't know why he would be
made as acting advisor when it's like
yeah this is a guy that made a joker
film as we're not really consciously not
involved
the whole point is the separateness
that's why it drives so like it's like
asking like the people from like
everything everywhere all at once i mean
like advice for us just because it's a
good film so i'm so
these are the exact same people who uh
when nolan made his films and then they
were like well we'll make our own and
they were like wait wait never mind you
are come back come back we liked this
yeah and so todd phillips it's like an
oscar somehow was born out of what we
made
please instagram a lot but i think the
strength of that film was the counter
programming so i don't think you can
counter counter programming like once a
punk band sells a certain amount of
albums are they still punk like is there
a certain amount of
what your expectations for furthering
that story even are and how do you
extrapolate that from being an indie
film broad strokes like the dc universe
is inherently shiny the reason this was
special is that it wasn't so i don't
think you can make a fully gritty
universe because at the end of the day
you're just a hot topic like you can't
live there but why why uh gritty
universe and not just you know auteurs
doing their one one shots i think that's
an option i think the strength of dc is
that i just don't know if they're gonna
let themselves do that when they're
calling it the d they've been fighting
to be the dc eu for ten years if they
had just gone okay we're going to make
these things separate we would have had
a thriving aquaman a thriving wonder
woman but they kept in my opinion kept
trying to put it together separately put
it together separate it so if you get
zack snyder to make a universe and then
stop it halfway you're gonna have a
problem if you get todd phillips to make
it universe and stop it athletic yeah
that's it you don't make a universe yeah
make ten make ten movies and maybe
that's the ted phillips influence right
maybe he's not telling him to build to a
new justice league or something like
that with all these interconnected films
maybe he's like let all these things
thrive
watch him still do it because booster
looks great right like we've seen a
couple images and like the things
they've let be their own thing i think
one of the greatest things about shazam
is it felt like its own thing yes i
don't i like that the voice of batman
wasn't ben affleck personally i liked
that the the caval moment wasn't
necessarily a capital moment so i think
the strength of dc is actually being a
counter programming to marvel and i
think the strength of the dc comics is
while right now it is currently batman
heavy those books you don't have to read
every one of those books in order to get
any of those books and the movies
haven't committed to that yet if todd
phillips did it yes but will they use it
here's a bet uh uh find me and and uh
zach will shave his head if i'm wrong uh
sorry zach todd phillips is at least
going to advise on a future gotham by
gaslight movie
oh i love that idea it's that's the
exact kind of
place i think that these things are
headed right where it's like like no we
are purposely we're so not connected
it's not even in our time period second
time it's you know it's uh there's not
what is batman without electronics do
you see black label yeah like dude like
so in the comics right now my favorite
line is dc black label because it is an
adult it's uh they're actually shaped
differently the books themselves are a
prestige format so you can't mix them up
with other comic books so they come out
more rarely if you did a dc black label
line of movies and had r-rated films
that live intentionally separately
oscars
then you have a universe that is strong
and that's a good that's why i put my
that's why i shave your head that's the
bed i'd put on sorry exactly sorry sorry
yeah we got to do it we got to do it i
like it
and not the luscious brand yeah
the only way this can happen is that i
saw 14 million uh things all of them
have zach's headset my father's
because i think you're wrong and i think
this rumor is going to turn out to be
false because he's got more to the story
yeah i think you're right i think this
rumor's gonna turn out to be not that
big a deal i don't doubt if todd
phillips never makes another film
before dc ever touches even joker again
yeah and instead
matt reeves becomes yes
that's what it feels like i would that's
i would choose matt reeves over to no no
i'm not disagreeing i choose matt reeves
over look top solved to choose matt
reeves over time
todd phillips has so much money because
of the hangover
project
he produces very well which is why this
rumor i took as like a second grain of
salt just because he is a very astute
producer like he works with joel silver
a lot who's a genius and gave us the 90s
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
he's the right man for this job he's
right men for age whereas matt reeves
he's already built out in one movie what
five villains a universe a texture a
tone an entirely new thing and he's got
two shows that theoretically might have
merged into one but that'll all
correlate and i think that he inherently
knows that batman and superman don't
work narratively together so he wouldn't
be as inclined to try to make this thing
that is superman punching a guy in a tin
suit right you're making the argument
that todd phillips is not going to be
the russo brothers he's going to be
kevin feige and then he brings in matt
concepcionally if if they so choose to
go away that they want an overseer i
think todd phillips would do it in the
way you're describing with gotham by
gaslight and those things but i think
that that would look different than what
people are assuming a coherent direction
is
and i think you know
we'll we'll see maybe in the next year
we'll get a picture of what 2023 and
beyond looks like i hope in the next
year we'll know what 23 maybe the next
eight months right by march 2023
2023. you're joking around today that
like you know last month marvel kevin
feige's like we planned out the next 10
years and today dc is like
someone's gonna direct something
well we know we're not recasting flash
that's all they know
that movie that's already shot we know
we're not going to change that that's as
far ahead as they can look speaking of
dc properties we are still in headlines
there has not been a different graph
technically technically we're at
headlines
but uh moving on other dc news uh the
directors of the upcoming hbo max
batgirl film
adil lrb and bilal fala
if i butchered those names uh both of
you uh but they confirmed that michael
keaton will be in that film as batman
yup
styling i feel like michael cohen is
just showing up on sets they give him a
script and he's like oh i'm gonna
i'm gonna improv this
i'll bet zach's hair that like he's not
in that movie for more than five minutes
and it's just him saying uh i want to
form a team
i bet it has something to do with that
batman
him saying a line that he said to the
joker and improv why is the first thing
we hear from batman a line that only
makes sense in the context of the joker
he's like you want to get crazy that
doesn't even make sense as it's not a
catchphrase why are you using that again
and now they're putting it into the hbo
max show putting him as a correlative
thing to tie this universe together it
doesn't even i love it
it's i don't love it i don't love it at
all i wouldn't put any money into it but
it's jordan
there you go george clooney just go
crazy if you're gonna make it that crazy
i love right now the feeling of like not
just being like a nerd but like a pop
culture fan because it's like when we
were little and there were the very
clear action heroes right it was like
arnold schwarzenegger and sylvester
stallone and and bruce will swear and we
were like imagine if they teamed up one
day and like we were like movie studios
and then the expendables kind of thing
happen right that's like all that's
happening right now is like what if
michael keaton came back and also uh
darth vader is going to have another
fight with obi-wan like every single
thing it's cause we're the suits now
probably aren't weird
those actors need money yeah right
they're like hey you know what yeah yeah
yeah the money's going i mean we're
what's the catchphrase we're trying to
work into the break room every day every
time an mcu actor is like i'd happily
appear in 12 more of these films in
series right like they'll like keep
getting checks
thirsty
yeah the thirsty actor
thirsty
also going back to our childhoods can
you imagine a day when we don't yet have
the amalgam universe but we do have two
universes where michael keaton is
gathering people we've got him gathering
the sinister six we've got him gathering
batman's and yet we might somehow
through people consuming each other have
michael keaton play the two people that
can cause amalgam like the guy from our
childhood is the guy that's both
connecting these universes which is like
white is also so cool at the same time
because he was in multiplicity so
there's more right
yeah yeah yeah we need we need the
photocopy of a photocopy to get into
these
this is the multiplicity verse
all of them have branched out
um uh speaking of uh multiplicity i
don't think there's a direct connection
it is a normal word you can just be used
yeah great uh speaking of films um
actually this is not a film either but
uh we got a quote you know john watts
helmer of the three-time holland
spider-man films uh was quoted he's
producing this upcoming star wars series
skeleton crew starring jude law and some
children
and he was quoted he it was an instagram
post by christian harloff uh he said it
had a clone wars feel to it you have no
idea what that means
you just talked about literally
so basically what i gathered was they
want that uh kind of prequel but rapid
pace like i think that the prequels are
love them or hate them they have a
slower pace than a lot of the other star
wars things with you know the politics
and those things i think what they're
saying is they want to make sure that
people the prequel fans feel happy they
want that emblem clip and i think that's
what like john watts was kind of
describing with those things so that's
what i gather from this uh i think it's
a pacing thing but i could totally be
wrong clone wars he means the film's
more than like the [ __ ] the animation
well i think it is the animated show but
like that show like moved but was still
a very cool flavor a lot of that there's
action and a lot of time passage yeah
but like it moves but then again uh we
didn't direct i just think it's very
funny that i literally we were filming a
rewatch thing we're watching all the toy
stories but i will i will ask the man
we were guessing that he was just like i
had to think of something
he looked there was a clone horse poster
right behind
tatooine feel to it
i assume i think this is a good faith
assumption this is a direct insult to
dave filoni and john favreau what's
going on he's not referencing any of the
live-action star wars series is going
actually it wouldn't be an insult to
dave felony just to john favreau right
if you're wrong you'll shave your head
right fair and you know what can't shave
your head twice
or i mean it's like you can't unring a
bell that's right you can't put that
just back there
that's right uh oh and then you know we
have uh we have so much release news far
ahead of time we already know when films
are coming out in 2023 we got kind of a
surprise release news just today
that multiverse of madness is gonna be
dropping on disney plus june 22nd three
weeks in three weeks from now it's going
to be on there it's all right it's still
there number two number three movie at
the box are about like streaming or like
digital downloads or the physical copies
they're just like oh we're gonna put on
disney players i think this is the
beginning of a new streaming awards
because we had that phase one streaming
wars pre-pandemic and it was like all
right everyone talk about your slate
change and then the pandemic cabinet is
like what if all of our movies are now
on the thing and now we're getting into
an age where we're in this conversation
movies are going to be a hybrid thing
and i think we're going to see a lot of
companies go yeah we're going to release
this early here we won't actually talk
about any other format of release you
need to be on these things to be
exclusive and have that especially with
marvel having the the tv and film stuff
but i think we're gonna over the next
two years see a lot of people fighting
to get distribution rights early like i
think it's gonna be like the 90s when
vhs was kind of like
fading into dvd and a lot of people were
like oh but six months earlier andy i
think we're going to see that i think
this streaming mafia is in play here
because april match just threw out like
secrets of dumbledore yeah
out of nowhere
i think they see netflix on the ropes
and they're like that's what i'm saying
we're going to see people like roberto
i think we're gonna see that now well
well what you were just touching on i'll
just pretend is my point the uh
800 yeah i discovered him yeah yeah
anyway 800 million dollar movie right
not accurate but like these insane
budgets at the same exact time that
netflix just
it kind of leaked we're not going to
spend a lot of money on our movies we're
going out and i also think this this
dovetails with the conversation we're
going to have later this also speaks to
the weakness of movie theaters the only
thing that was holding this back
pre-pandemic from studios being able to
do this is because movie theaters would
get pissed at them because they have a
guaranteed window of you know however
many weeks that you're not gonna um
release your film in any other format
but the movie theaters are just
struggling to stay alive right now
excuse me this is top gun on the phone
oh yeah
i was going to say tom cruise has shot
marvel down he has saved cinema again
and you know the only guy that can do it
the 60 year old actor that's right from
our childhood but i do think there's
going to be a wave of people the
exhibition world isn't dead yet and i do
think there's going to be a conversation
where we need the theatrical under
because of the netflix conversation i
think netflix putting up that white flag
shows that we need movies that are going
to make money scorsese can't make this
stuff anymore over there it's not going
to be put on hbo you need that
theatrical window for older people and
theater lovers to actually get the movie
to make some money i think
those aren't going anywhere and and you
know scorsese uh has made right
theatrical films his whole career i
think like
it it just the
power and influence of
theaters over change industry right is
like dramatically and in fact right
there's some this is a conversation for
another day but like there's all these
these moves behind the scenes to get rid
of the um monopoly restrictions on
studios being able to own theaters i
think that's what's netflix already owns
theaters like uh you know that could be
another branch i don't think movie
theater is going to go away but though
our
interaction with them will certainly
dramatically change over time well
speaking of scorsese's next film the
search for the fantastic four
journalists here it is that's the
transition right there
that's the transition
right there for you okay uh justin
crowell deadline senior film reporter
stated in tweets that marvel doesn't
expect the role to be filled anytime
soon which is insane this movie is
supposed to come out in 2023 i would bet
zach's hair that it doesn't come out 23
now we need to stop
[Laughter]
do you guys think that this movie's
gonna get delayed they have not even
picked a director and as far as we know
they've cast one
you know how disney loves to do like
those holi the family holiday like
releases so it could come out in
december 2023 there's also more than the
uh who directs all of tom cruise's
movies except for
mcqueen
yeah uh shoots
like 70 of those movies before the
script is even not even lost before
there's dialogue that's why
i'm sure everyone really hates him well
so i thought that and i was like
especially like as a writer i'm like how
dare you think that you can and then i
watch the movie i'm like movie's good
this is awesome
you know we know marvel does that too
with like previous and stuff
the director shows up and they're like
here's your third act we've already
started doing this we've done the
preview
elizabeth olsen saying i've never met
this man uh about john i mean what's
interesting about fantastic four is they
don't have masks so you can't really
like start doing a lot maybe the thing
you could start working i also imagine
mr fantastic has already got a lot
we are under the assumption that this is
true we don't know maybe there is a
director hired maybe there is casting
already done and the the super airtight
ship of marvel right has had no leaks up
until they delay all the time they're
looking at a lot of big name directors
for this movie supposedly that's what
these tweets are about uh there's rumors
that they're looking for like another
oscar winner you know cloisow oscar
winner though she was brought in before
she won her oscar like won it
in the process of that movie coming out
a lot of fans have talked about brad
bird who directed the incredibles a
great
almost like a pseudo fantastic board
pretty much he's done a couple live
action movies he did a mission
impossible and it was good ghost
protocol which one
like myself wish were much
let's talk about tomorrowland guys yes
would it be fun no no who should direct
well here's who i think should direct
the next fantastic
okay okay this is a wild one this is a
i'm gonna give you a wild pick uh he's a
guy he's a guy uh he he'd fallen out of
my director graces for a little while
but he really came back last year with a
great movie is this person problematic
no i hope not
he is a guy he's a classic talk about
childhood let steven coming out
i i thought i thought my side story was
great i think minority report is a great
movie recorded very great question it is
worth the while
yeah
everything else in the middle what does
he have to do what does he have to gain
from this he loves he's having fun i
think doing this
movie might be a lot of in a movie about
family he loves movies about families
yeah and a dad that is problematic and
uh a west side story had the scale right
for a musical you know like wasn't even
here here's the problem i think i mean
it'd be a dope movie don't get me wrong
and i love steven spielberg like you to
be able to fit within the marvel machine
he would have to give up so much of the
autonomy and the creative freedom that
he gets to enjoy on equally big
have two seconds to himself and i got a
thousand
let a big name come in and just kind of
handle it okay so i think sorry real
quick all right and let's do this for
everybody's a little bit so it's
spielberg's movie when does it take
place i i i like that that story that
was kind of around that's going to be
set in the past a little bit yeah me too
yeah so said it in the 60s it was the
john watts rumor right yeah that would
be this like separate story let him
handle it and the end of it is very
captain america where they jump to the
future
but and it's and it's a family movie
it's a family it's about this family
trying to like keep themselves together
even though uh cosmic rays have torn
them apart
and the thing's mad because he can't
walk down the street you can't date
anymore he's gotta date a blind lady all
right
yeah and then what is there just the
shot of like there's something there's a
lot of big problems in the background
i'm just thinking of that classic
spielberg shot of like one little thing
and then there's a bunch of them right
that happens true that's the class
there you go jessica who are you going
to say uh going to make this quick i
think it should be spike lee and i think
it should be placed in uh
freaking uh prohibition time
we gotta go we do have to speed this up
a little bit because we have three other
segments and we haven't finished
headlines speed round okay i want to do
it set in the 60s and it gets to now but
that's by way of it being in the quantum
mania world where we saw that little
city that we've teased for a lot i would
have the main villain be a nihilist
because that would tie into the negative
zone i would make the negative zone the
quantum realm that way you save time as
far as continuity and you actually catch
up to the mcu and i would use an ielts
as a way to have a villain that is very
streamlined very simple he wants to
consume and then you set up doctor doom
through wakanda
you got the political aspect of you know
you put them there and you have them
looming you have the emperor palpatine
you get a one-off villain so you
introduce the family you can actually
have time with all four of them you
don't have to lean on the doctor doom
which is very like important he's the
fifth lead i would have i this is the
one thing you prepped me for so i i over
prepped i got four different directors i
want to do wait because this is a speed
zone this is this is this round right
here
and i have a full 20 minute pitch in
this the real rejects we did a whole
thing right at koi's comic corner my
debut episode is about the fantastic
four pitch but my uh four directors that
i would want to have are either the
daniels who just did everything
everywhere all at once because i think
they would understand the wonkiness of
that kirby-esque flavor that crazy o.g
stanley in the 60s i think they could
get the
side that would make it unique from
other team books i would then say uh my
second pick would be soderbergh because
he handles teams really well he invests
you in characters we haven't seen sober
do anything big in a while i think it'd
be fun to see an oxford director who
just handled kimmy really great indie
film i'd like to see him come back to a
big pizzazz brad pitt spectacular uh my
weirdest pick is george clooney himself
we mentioned
i think he's a great director for
americana and i think that marvel's
first family would be interesting to
leave into a less toxic americana and
have like the leatherheads feel the
conventions of a dangerous minefield do
all those things and then my weirdest of
all picks they get progressively weirder
wes anderson a very symmetrical dash are
you fantastic for i want a very
symmetrical but i could see us having a
movie that feels like you're reading a
mic all red comic you feels like you're
reading a a very specific separate from
the rest of the mcu on purpose much like
sam raimi if kevin feige wants that
those are my four beauty good answer
we'll skip phone calls
[Laughter]
those are his ideas
uh five words uh or i don't i haven't
counted the number one
justice for edgar wright oh let's go
bring it back
bring it back i'll one-up you uh it's
matthew vaughan it's matthew vaughn it's
kingsman meets x-men first class it's a
non-cheesy it's set in the 60s it's
non-cheesy fantastic four but also still
like cla classic at the same time that's
what i was like [ __ ]
[Music]
carter
starters
60s why can't it be set in modern day
what's our problem with that i think the
60s is i i think time periods and movies
are just beautiful
freaking um um freaking the chess one
the chestnuts gambling queen's game
that's right that's a chestnut that's
right
please give it i think getting that feel
and seeing like the art they can make
with that budget just like making their
house making the clothes doing all that
stuff is just beautiful so it's just
baxter
it's also much less complicated because
we've got a lot going on here
um where have you been this was this
entire conversation spurred by no news
about fantastic four just wait till we
get actual news yeah imagine how much
less to say uh but uh speaking of news
the news about nutrition guys is that
black greens is great we want to thank
our friends at athletic greens for
sponsoring today's show uh i've got a
bottle here of ag-1 the signature
athletic greens product that we've been
sipping all week all week tommy bechtold
not here right now but also a big fan of
athletic greens it's got like 71 uh
vitamins and minerals in there the nice
thing about athletic greens and we're
about to transition into talking about
movie theater
snacks okay let's say your summer diet
consists mostly of popcorn dr pepper and
raisinets okay that's a delicious diet
but that's maybe not covering all the
things that your body needs to thrive
and stay alive right and that's where
athletic greens comes in it's like a
little nutritional insurance you know
you know if you've got a spoonful of
this stuff in a glass of cold water in
the morning
you're you're okay for the rest of the
day whether you hit your salads and your
asparagus or not and probiotics are in
there right which are not in any of
those things you mentioned earlier yes
yes uh keep that gut health it also has
some cool stuff that even helps you like
be a little sharper right which we could
all use regardless of the season um so
uh we want to thank athletic greens you
should grab yourself some right now is
the time it's the perfect time to
reclaim your health and arm your immune
system with convenient daily nutrition
throw a scoop in there no need for a
million different pills and powders and
tinctures uh i love the word
a great tinctures and i know it's aimed
at me and my tinctures yes
tinctures we call them tiny tincture
orphanage um
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune support and vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is go to
athleticgreens.com
break room the link in this video
description as well again that's
athleticgreens.com break room take
ownership over your health pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance we
also want to uh take a moment to plug
we've got a nice t-shirt model here
who's wrapping our special obi-wan
themed latest obsession shirt oh that's
nice look at that oh that's nice do you
guys read arabic i do not unfortunately
empires most wanted uh close
uh empire's most hung oh okay get out of
here you're wondering
this obi-wan
bears a strong resemblance to you were
you the model the life model for this
everyone uh i
you know what i did not notice that but
he is mostly eyebrows and beer
yeah
he's got a little uh a smaller little
man in him too
we've all got a little baby
inside we got a little
tatooine yeah got some uh empire ships
yes moisture evaporation
you can get this shirt it's a limited
edition latest obsession shirt when you
buy this you can unlock the ability to
leave a shout out that shows up on our
wikileaks show every week uh mt no i'm
sorry tommy and eric we'll we'll read
that out loud we'll roll it at the
bottom that's a cool thing uh we've got
a bunch of other cool obi-wan stuff at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can grab this
shirt there i'm repping um an asgard ale
or asgard ipa shirt that you can also
you can find that at the epic hero shop
uh there's a whole line of like uh boozy
uh superhero inspired instead of white
claw there's a wakanda claw shirt it's
cool guys take it to the pool party this
year uh this summer you'll have a good
time with it um but now
uh we want to transition here now
normally this would be the place where
we do mandatory fun okay by far the most
popular segment on the show uh the only
segment that people know by name uh and
we're not gonna call this mandatory fun
we're gonna call it zack snacks
nice oh there's no graphics
not only is there no graphic but he
clearly was looking for a close-up that
was not given to him
i don't know in fact i specifically
requested i was like john i know you
could throw together a gorgeous graphic
instead i would prefer a moment of
silence oh sorry say one more time zack
snacks
thank you great okay
good good all right moving on
so there were a couple news items uh in
the last week that inspired me to talk
about this i'm a big snack head my i
think my twitter name is still snack
huddleston um love love food love snack
talk and uh one one sad piece of news
supposedly
there is
uh worry that there's gonna be a popcorn
shortage this summer i don't buy it you
don't buy it i think this is the popcorn
industry big trying to drive sales
everyone's gonna start buying more
popcorn now because they're like i'm
going to get it now the coast divorce
it's always going to be playing i mean i
think there's logistics issues in the
fields of corn
get out of here
no this is his dumb speech
based upon the popcorn fields
there's popcorn in those fields
gentlemen we just have to harvest it
yeah uh speaking of popcorn
pop some marvel red bachelor here in the
office
zach grab stuff i'm gonna give a shout
outs real quick to all of the super
chats we're going to get to you guys
after uh zach's snacks uh and we'll
answer some of your questions yes and
there's some real i'm i'm fully
triggered by tibetan mastiff saying uh
keeping it 100 more bs was better than
the batman wow
it's morbid time indeed so this just got
me thinking in general about movie
theater snacks right our habits the
things we like i got some whoppers some
uh milk duds and thank you and and some
raisin nets those are three of the i
believe the top ten movie theater
snacks as released fandango also did a
poll recently they released a bunch of
different data they'd done all these
wide-ranging polls of people's uh movie
theater snacking habits right things
they preferred they did a whole segment
on the favorite candy to dump into
popcorn does anybody hear a candy in
your popcorn bunch of crunches
absolutely a bunch of crumbs the texture
mixes well but it allows for like a nice
weight distribution and then you get
little spikes of chocolatey goodness but
it doesn't settle too deep these are all
very heavy you get them at the bottom of
the bag bunch of crunch little float
boys i like a peanut m m yeah it gets
that butter on the shell the shell keeps
it intact don't get the chocolate on
your fingers but then the chocolate's
melty inside they still got a peanut so
it's healthy you can tell you're done
good fats
throw it in the chat if you like uh
let's run a poll real quick are you a
candy and the popcorn person or do you
think that's heresy also if so uh tell
us what kind of candy are you dumping a
lot of m m's in the chat reese's pieces
are great too ever since eating reese's
pieces in the popcorn it's the move very
nice
in the popcorn a little peanut buttery
goodness someone said skittles and i
don't believe that no that is wrong
[Laughter]
do you put anything in your popcorn you
seem disgusting i'm very disgusted
horrified you guys are all monsters
yeah they should die and i hope
[Laughter]
impossible to consume that and not have
everyone in this smelling radiation
expressions
it was orange chicken
and you're stabbing with
no just like nobody's like really paying
attention to what you're reaching yeah
wow
i'm tired of these movie theaters
selling like cheeseburgers and hot wings
and stuff i'm tired of that i love that
thing
i've witnessed multiple times philip go
for that slice of pizza go for that
and then you got a reclining seat a
little blanket little pillow action but
there's chefs i went i don't know all
that it's a little shopping i bet
there's a roach in that chair
that's extra protein
fingers with dipping sauces it's dark i
can't tell what i'm dipping into that's
the existence i guess the screen is
bright actually no the last movie i
think no maverick was brightest maverick
was favorite that's because it's from
the 80s
like the 80s that orange
when i'm trying to lose weight when i'm
cutting i like to bring in steamed
artichokes because when you bring in an
artichoke it's like popcorn it takes a
long time to eat and i usually dip it in
balsamic way
so but it takes you have to like you get
to peel it and bite it and dip it so
it's a long journey but that way it
takes two hours you got hot from the
house no it's real time
that's where you steam it yeah
like a steamed artichoke it takes two
hours so it's burning for a movie and i
will say i i love a good steamed
artichoke and it's probably one time
that place in time is not during fast
five or objection okay so that's cookie
dough
brandon put eminem's in his popcorn and
jessica called him a monster
and then brexit panda express i don't
mix it with anything i just eat it
yeah it's not the issue
antioxidants vitamin c and k i'm getting
healthier when i've got a minute when i
went and saw blockers i made a taco bowl
and i was like and i was like and i was
like i'm not gonna leave this at home
i'm bringing it with me and i put it on
somewhere and i brought it with me to
the cinnamon
you're looking for an outlet for a
toaster oven
58 of chad says what no when asked if
they put in the problem
that is very different the fandango poll
i believe had uh similar numbers
actually so maybe yeah but that was
russia it was behind that yeah and we
know that they're huge goober fans
someone's one of the chances oh geez boy
that's wild
dot dot dot
now does anybody else have any like
interesting habits like off-screen uh
producer john and i were chatting a
little bit people that like a
nutritional oh yeah
old bay seasoning maybe a chili powder
yeah
it's good
spectacular i'll add a powder to
anything yeah yeah i would say during
cocaine top gum my wife and i we love
popcorn drink covered we started making
our own popcorn at home and it is so
much better you pop in the corner you
pop the coin yourself you get a whirly
pop they're not sponsoring this show but
whirly pop is like the greatest of what
sponsor the show you cowards smiley face
it's got a little crank on it you put
the you put the oil in we use coconut
oil you put your popcorn kernels in you
spin it in 30 seconds you got popcorn
that's good
that's a great little
nutritional that's a great transition
because i wanted to transition we're
talking a little bit about real quick
whoppers or milk tides neither
whoppers yeah milk duds oh i would say
waffles too i like them you don't say
raisins
these were my dad's candy and i'm not
allowed to have it
oh yeah
what our binging content
snack routine might be because we were
kind of inspired jessica and i both
grabbed some stranger things branded
snacks stranger things is out there
right now uh got some 3d doritos some
regular cool ranch doritos just the ones
i got they also have some themed sour
patch kids
um now these are like great you can grab
these in the grocery store for your
binge watching but do you have a
a snack habit when you're watching we
make a lot of popcorn yeah
[Music]
i eat healthy i try to eat very healthy
so at the movies the reason why zach
sees me eat these things is because like
a raw hot dog is the only the closest
thing to the 16 rawhide okay you're
gonna have uh that's that's my favorite
move the raw hot dog
i
do have to do that there because people
are there but when i'm binging alone
yeah and i'm in a mood where i'm gonna
snack
it i'm not kidding it is bad i will
spend like a hundred dollars i will
order it all from a service called go
puff also not sponsoring this show
yeah yeah like a weed store yeah
that was like a snack store when you're
smoking it's what you use it's after uh
and i will order
every flavor of ben and jerry's ice
cream
in a pint together and then it will also
order every cut
there's a lot more every kind of ice
cream sandwich
that that they have and then cones and
then tortilla chips oh my gosh like and
then i i mean honestly i just like i'm
hey i'm binge watching i'm binge eating
yeah yeah yeah i i approve of what
phillip said but i'll give you the poor
person's method
come on delivery ice cream you go you
got a taco bell you get a you get the 12
party pack tacos
and you only you go into a movie theater
with them
and then you get one ticket for maverick
that's some pizzas back it's 4.99 and
then you get those they're sold out
right now but it's coming back two
gallon ice cream that they had in
elementary school yeah the three colors
with the clear plastic plastic if you're
going calorie density there's also this
place called costco and they sell a five
pound tub of cookie dough and in my
experience very little tops a five pound
cookie dough i had a tapeworm for seven
years taught me the power of cookie
dough didn't know how to tape for him
but i learned the power of five pounds
thank you sorry you guys brought your
bravery of like telling us about your
table it was terrifying
seven years i was 22 long
that's next
time new rockstar
speaking of demogorgon yeah
they did not make me love sugar like
something that's so shook we need
to switch oh my
gosh but like my cookie dough habit is
like it's like nicotine now because i
like i needed sugar all the time because
i was feeling that thing so i can
literally house five pounds of cookie
dough you were pregnant
it wasn't there in the ship too
what was its name a fred because i
wanted to kill fred so i called the drop
down
um jessica and i were talking though
these are all great snacks sour patch
kids and doritos are always delicious
but a little disappointing these aren't
special flavors they just put the
packaging on the regular
you know again i go way back i like an
ecto cooler okay i like give me a
dedicated flavor to this ip yeah
sponsorship or like uh upside down
debbie cakes yes well we even had in one
of our very first rogue theory episodes
we ate they released special stranger
things season three
baskin-robbins flavors that we sampled
there was like upside down pineapple
cake or something you know what i mean
it's a kind of clever name i don't even
mind if it's the same chip just make it
look different like the demogorgon or
something because i liked when like they
had the shrek ketchup at uh burger king
and it was green
you think you think at the factories
those that like stretch where they're
like i make doritos that are triangle
shaped for years and every once in a
while i have to make it look like you
know a transformer or something you
think that's an exciting time for them
or miserable i think it's exciting you
know there's creative team at frito-lay
that spent months coming out with a
golden ratio yes new new new names all
that stuff and it got shot down by the
the big wigs in the c-suite because they
were too afraid to upset the consumers
of america those
engineers it probably was engineers
think about the shape of a chip it's a
triangle it goes perfectly right into
your mouth it doesn't cut it
down that's the size you know there's a
gap because
your triangle strength
just like your throat yeah
[Laughter]
now i feel like i have to um uh let's uh
brandon can you uh throw a couple of
those super chats out today
uh
jeff bost asked this early on and i
don't know what it means anyone else
think the skrull are jack
and hagar from game of thrones
uh
yes basically uh no i don't think it is
no so shout out to
jack and hagar who's currently on
stranger things he plays the russian
guard uh who befriends hopper uh myra
pedron said can we please have koi every
week i love when he talks fast laughing
my a off i can't say what she was
laughing up to inspire the a off yeah i
am impressed with your your speed you
got those ideas i was challenged i felt
like i want to make sure the run time
hit i got you yeah that worm turned you
into an auctioneer yeah
max savage big fan of epic hero shop
said plan to buy the highest ground
shirt so i can wear it to church and
message oh gosh
i support that but also
confront your religious leaders with the
power of obi-wan kenobi you know what's
great about it okay so you stop at the
highest ground shirt and it looks like
stained glass and has like obi-wan and
like a jesus pose i guarantee that
they're not gonna know it's not a jesus
well there's that's the best
but it has like tie fighters that is
amazing but you know that like fighters
are just angels
those are the philistines coming to
destroy us that's beautiful
fighters
our good friend chrissy uh she was
commenting it's a great point uh the
conversation we're having about the past
coming back our heroes from the past she
said we went from writing the fame of
popular actors to bring in new fans to
an existing fandom to now bringing back
og actors to appeal to the people who
were kids then and now are adults and
have the money so
we had to we had to start over so that
there would be new fans and then they
got those new fans but then they lost
the adult fans and now the adult fans
need the nostalgia oh tom cruises your
keanu reeves your sigourney weavers
there's like a wave of that 80s
right who was andy griffith all grown up
what's that matlock was the same actor
from andy griffith okay the andy
griffith show that's how they brought
him in
this is how we bring older viewers into
them
wake up matlock fans wake
[Music]
uh mr krabs saying me seeing john in
multiverse of madness quote identity
theft is not a joke jim uh we all know
you love the office yeah it'll never die
unfortunately
uh s elizabeth wants us to pitch a
what-if episode parentheses please
please she did ask nice to meet you kind
of s elizabeth um whoa that that's a
tall task to pitch uh uh how about it
doesn't have to be marvel it doesn't oh
what is anything oh well what is it i
like that well my big what if uh this
was what i wanted disney to do when they
did the live action aladdin okay and i'm
waiting for marvel to do this too i want
some gender swapping going on i wanted
the live action aladdin to be jasmine
was the street rat uh who comes across
the genie and aladdin is the prince who
lives in the castle or whatever it's the
story of jasmine going from ranks to
riches that's why okay that's so funny
because inspired by the pinocchio
trailer we got
earlier this week i want a roll reversal
there i don't want it
builds up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
um what if uh jessica
adopted
four more cats
and then i just have more cats this is
to my uh my roommate
can i get what if this episode happened
and it already did and this is how
you're finding out cats are in my office
and i bring them home by
accident uh in the vein of multiverse
madness what if when xavier met scarlet
witch he remembered mutants and that
caused like a domino effect of mutants
being activated in the mcu by way of her
saying mutants instead of no more
mutants and that being a way to tie in
the fox universe into our universe and
then at the end deadpool is there
because i need that
beauty
uh my what if is uh uh what if luke was
the one that wa became prince of
alderaan like
[Applause]
still still like doing that laying down
pose though
still looking into the lightsabers
little buzz of me first aren't you bro
wow that's a good one i would really
enjoy seeing that and hey disney owns
all that crap now you never know um and
then we'll end on one more super chat
just me saying yes morbius is way better
than any bat punk movie i'm just you
know what i just wanted to read that
just to end on an incendiary note
people just trying to stir things up uh
all of tomorrow's episode is gonna be
yeah just insulting uh much more popular
uh characters via morbius uh but thank
you all so much for watching thank you
uh all for being here especially koi
welcome to the show
are you allowed to plug your thing oh
yeah so i just started a new show uh
thrill rejects called koi's comic corner
literally the first episode is me doing
a 20-minute dissertation on how i bring
the fantastic four the next one we
haven't announced yet but i'll do it
here uh it's how i bring in wolverine
into the greater mcu oh that's not how
you'd think and i also have a podcast
called koicast i'll stay on my own
youtube channel that i don't use nearly
enough and i'm really trying to get into
tik tok so uh twitter instagram tick
tock tick tock's hard i'm old but that's
where i'm at mostly because it's
apparently the most relevant
not to build an audience yeah
this is awesome thank you guys
thank you everybody for watching we'll
be back tomorrow fridays get weird on
the breakdown friday okay you're weird
sometimes there's alcohol involved often
i mean if you thought like our snack
discussion was wide-ranging uh just
imagine how many tapeworms we're going
to talk about tomorrow the boys comes
out tomorrow yeah the boys underground
be back tomorrow
watch three boys tonight yes yeah real
quick shout out to uh the real break
room fans who were have seen enough
episodes of the show to understand why i
was not allowed to eat a single one of
these snacks
the entire time we're gonna we're gonna
get into these snacks off camera uh
thank you so much for watching we'll see
you tomorrow and in the future bye-bye
bye
[Music]
you